[Music]
in extreme a bonding news submitted by
Chinese ramen hmm a proud mom lets her
six-year-old son drive her car at 80
miles an hour
whoa weights your old son who's pressing
the pedal though the son big-ass [ __ ]
kid I'm thinking that he's on her lap
how can you reach yeah I'd like that
here hmm remember that kid that stole
the van he went viral but he was like
old was yeah wasn't he like nice okay I
just made that [ __ ] up I just threw that
out but this was submitted by someone
called Chinese ramen how is this real
all this submission name I mean like
their name Chinese I don't trust nothing
coming from a Chinese Roman hi my name
is Chinese ramen I'm believing nothing
you're saying that's a dope name when
you say it out loud Chinese on it yeah
is there not Chinese rum for the Robin
it's Japanese ramen I think maybe he's
asking maybe they're mixed oh yeah
anyway so this happened in Russia
[Music]
Australia as well Australia yeah
maybe an Outback so this mother of four
who's 29 she posted a video of her six
year old son driving her Hyundai so
Laura Solaris Solaris mm-hmm on an empty
Highway this is a Hyundai commercial I
knew it
so here's the mom and her six-year-old
were sick so it looks weird honey has a
weird face why does he look like a South
Park character we think there's
something wrong with him
are you sure to say Japanese porn she
looks completely normal there's the
penetration have me right in her ear oh
that's far doesn't when you say this
does poor pixelated in Japanese poor
supposed to say something but I feel
like I'm supposed to address it though
that looks like it was rendered in a
PlayStation 1 for some reason how come
we're watching Minecraft right now so
it's an empty Highway that's fine
the hazard lights are on everything they
don't have seatbelts on
and they didn't gasps please and it's
raining yeah but where's I have no idea
how the pedal is being pushed how big is
this [ __ ] looks like it's
raining - I think he's on our lap yeah
and I had to put the chair all the way
pulled back and she's holding the phone
like this what lesson does this teach a
six-year-old she's all kinds of [ __ ]
up empty gas no seat belt on she's like
excuse me go around yeah around look at
that [ __ ] dude
there's a Czech banjo cat taking money
this car is all kinds of [ __ ] dog I've
seen I mean it wouldn't be the first
time I've seen somebody who have a baby
on their lap and drive yeah I did that
wait what yeah my parents put me on oh
yeah like this is after you see the
video you're like it's corny like you
dumb for posting it stupid are you to
post it right yeah I think she's cool
insulin media I'm cool point out that
there are reports that this kid has
recently gone I surgery what the [ __ ]
all we can see either side knowing he
can because we're gonna just judge you
know let the six-year-old be the judge
while he's driving the road I don't like
to do LASIK when you're six that's the
only kind of surgery available he's a
six year old he hit he's not gonna
steadily do this [ __ ] or even focus on
that what if he just faint rambling off
like that it great what if something
goes in the middle of the road you think
the mom like okay whatever so we got a
surgery you can't see [ __ ] any driving
yeah what if a Russian seal pops out of
nowhere and you did your Lantana Russian
seals are land animals everyone knows
everybody knows yeah until shoes for the
messy okay I know they're saying that
Russia's legal driving age is 18 that's
the big deal twelve years less come on
my and in there a speed limit is 75
miles an hour going right so she
captioned it with happy son and then
oh happy my son is so happy cool mom
award it's all that matters that kids
getting set up with failure like giving
her [ __ ] for it and so she says I live
the way I want I regret nothing I am
calm about everything I do not need your
crippling comment and that sounds
Russian as [ __ ] yeah and competence I'm
not tried living my life you don't have
a right to judge she probably has a dope
life I need to train him now for when
I'm [ __ ] up so he knows what to do
clearly training him at six
why can't I'm going to be us out why
can't this woman react to most things in
our world and not like kids driving at
six like I think that that's the
appropriate answer for most [ __ ] that
everyone goes nuts about yeah but this
one well cause he's [ __ ] wrestling
bears and [ __ ] true you don't know
nothing this is boring she's nothing
so she adds I am proud that my children
can easily drive a car for her I loved
every minute of this life spent with my
boys I so much like being a mother I
like spending all my time only with my
beloved sons so then that's when people
started saying that they were gonna
report her to the police
yo death must be around the corner for
her like to just be like I'm living
every second hi guys so my six-year-old
is gonna learn how to drive cuz I might
not be here tomorrow we fly plane yeah
she says there there is a lot but it
doesn't it does not say that children
can't go behind the wheel let literally
the pokeball lady yeah she said let's
compete and who knows traffic rules best
oh not you
we should play again and then she said
do not comment on my life or teach me
how to live I don't care what my life
looks like I'm not interested in your
private life and I would like it to be
mutual I do everything right and if you
think that I am NOT right it is your
problem did she post a [ __ ] video
right that's what I was about
so she cares about opinion it's not
private and on top of that it is a
public matter cuz she's on a public road
your dumb [ __ ] Oh God
she said that the reason why she's
teaching her kids to drive over the
speed limit she wants to be trouble
she's a mother of four because she wants
him to be a cosmonaut by the time he's
13 is an astronaut in Russia okay thank
you for educating me I like how your
eyes wink at two separate times like
it's a [ __ ] you mm-hmm it's a double
[ __ ] you I couldn't help you there Steve
I didn't know what a cause but I had no
idea oh I thought you would intelligent
one that's why I know what's the bit
today but yeah so it's the reason why
she's teaching your kids is because
they're saying actually saying that
these boys don't have their dad in their
life and that's why she's responsible
for teaching them toaster drive and how
their necks gonna learn how to shoot a
gun I was gonna say so at 6:00 you learn
how to drive at 7:00 you shoot gun at
8:00 what do you do at 8:00 fight a
polar bear there you go the ultimate
test you survived all of them
you become man if you don't I adopt
polar bear as my son yeah you keep
outside polar bear sleep until you win
oh there's some parents that are
probably really like that though mm-hmm
I feel like Russia just plays by a whole
different set of rules
can you imagine the polar bear driving
the car it's just like [ __ ] you he's my
son I'd love to spend time with my polar
bears people in Russia or a lot of these
comments coming from people in America
because what the what a hell am I
supposed to do in America calling
who-who am i calling a Russia yeah cuz
maybe all the Russians got her back
right [ __ ] you guys American shut up
this is how we raise men been driving
since five years
so say the boys on the inside of the car
my boy we learned on the outside of the
car
and now everybody's like your accents
are [ __ ]
we put saddle on roof we teach him the
hard way for another video
serial poster yeah where she she loves
this attention where she drove with her
baby in her lap so her eldest son is
nine and her youngest is nine months oh
my god is this mommy as lordy I mean
I've driven with my car with my puppy in
my lap like it's the same as a nine
month old we didn't let the puppy drive
definitely didn't I think the car needs
to be maintained though that's where I'm
like damn you got empty gas check engine
light no seatbelt all this shit's
blinking damn man what the [ __ ] it's
like a slot machine I know she's like
[ __ ] you you don't know my driving
history yeah I know what your cars been
through you should see my old boy [ __ ]
you I know huh hmm this reminds me of
those [ __ ] teenage girls that go on
Maury or whatever they like I do what I
want
catch me outside yeah that [ __ ]
person then she's like a grown-ass woman
with that [ __ ] who had four kids yeah
catch me outside had to have her kid by
now no where's your man's at she doesn't
have oh right I forgot but she couldn't
find another one probably not maybe your
kids are [ __ ] [ __ ] the night one
yeah I picture her kids being the [ __ ]
dicks like at the moon head of moon
bounce
that of beating other kids invited over
the ones like pushy sticky kids she's
probably drunk in the back like hit him
harder don't like the bad guys in the
Mighty Ducks yeah those kids were
[ __ ] dicks what are you talking about
I'm like man every set latching uniforms
and it was all good and in the second
movie I think that they were actually
rushing serially like da [ __ ]
you actually watch the second one of
course yeah I was a white trash can yep
and I keep forgetting thank you Bologna
and white bread
that was his life yeah so was also same
it is pretty good Wonder Bread oh yeah
with yellow mustard oh we had meanings
my mom did one circle and then she would
put the sandwich together like smacking
it so I always saw her handprint because
she's making it for four kids you the
cheese the American cheese one American
slice an American one and then you get
the ruffle chips on the side if they
survive the day and then they were
usually dust by a lunchtime lunch lunch
pail I had a lunch bag like a brown bag
didn't sense every day huh giving those
bags away cheaper more cost-effective if
you had a lunchbox lunchbox well lunch
boxes were bulkier like getting the book
bag so you're able to maneuver that [ __ ]
around and yeah the ruffles had to
suffer I always wanted a brown bags
cause like it was like cooler yeah cuz
like you know when you when you have a
he-man lunchbox and Cheryl oh yeah
you're still a kid you're you're like at
like third or fourth grade the poor kids
like they're cooler than [ __ ] cuz they
have the [ __ ] bags and you're just
like [ __ ] I want to be an adult I'll be
poor too yeah anyway you're [ __ ]
changing and [ __ ] like you know how like
you know you're a man if you got boxers
mm-hmm and everyone else has tighty
whiteys you're [ __ ] a little boy
still yellow had to make me add tighty
whiteys for me and then I made her I was
like no more boxes and [ __ ] I won't
even go to school anymore if you like
please I need to get boxes she goes yeah
but your wiener is gonna be more snug
and better yeah
and she was right I don't I didn't like
boxers that much but dry warm any of the
[ __ ] away
[Music]